a real threat to vladimir putin that's
how commentators are describing kremlin
critic alexey navalny so
who is he a courageous and charismatic
opposition leader or an
opportunist fighting a personal vendetta
against president putin
well the russian authority certainly
responded nervously to his recent return
to moscow
navalny was immediately arrested in turn
he put out a documentary film
showing a giant palace allegedly
belonging to president putin
that triggered more claims and counter
claims and violent protests across the
country
so on to the point we ask navalny
against putin
who will win the russian showdown
[Music]
thanks very much indeed for joining us
here on to the point and with me in the
studio
is daria sukharchuk a freelance reporter
and presenter
born in russia and based in berlin daria
says navalny's investigations
and the attack on him have for the first
time politicized many
young people in russia also with us is
alexander
expert on russia an adviser to the
energy giant gazprom
he argues that russian society can live
with corruption
but if the younger generation feel
they're losing out that could change
quickly
and a very warm welcome to to stephen
pifer
academic analyst and former u.s
ambassador with a focus on europe on
russia and much else besides he says the
west should push back against the worst
of russian misbehavior
but it should also leave the door open
for dialogue
thank you for those three statements sir
thank you for being here and i'd like to
begin with you daria if i may and begin
with vladimir putin himself
he's clearly under pressure that's big
news he's under pressure from alexander
valni so tell us a little bit
about mr novani himself so
mr navalny has been around for over a
decade
he has been a big presence on the
bolotna square protests in 2012
which a lot of people here will probably
remember is the biggest
to date actually the protest that took
time that took part
took place this sunday were smaller
than what happened in voladni navani is
well known
for his videos and
i should say he knows how to speak the
language towards the young people that's
why i talked about it
in my statement so he is charismatic
he's charismatic and he knows how to
play this
irony how to make things stick
so for example his genius find in this
last uh video was that he talked not
only about the giant palace but he also
talked about the toilet brush for 700
euro
which became beneficial symbols of
protesters now if you noticed but a lot
of people turned up with toilet brushes
some haven't sprayed with gold or i've
seen one with the price tag 700 euro
which is something this kind of stuff
sticks
he definitely knows how to lead people
he's very well organized he's got the
so-called
headquarters like offices actually
without having an official political
party
his movement has
offices all over russia no political
party has a network like that
not united russia putin's party does not
have a network like this
this is why the protests the sunday were
remarkable
for the number of towns they took place
in we had about a hundred towns
small ones like tv not just moscow saint
petersburg and maybe novosibirsk
okay so there's pretty impressive stuff
uh does that mean that when we say the
uh alexander rao that he is the man
vladimir
putin fears the most is that true do you
buy into that
before answering i want to tell you i'm
uh of course
correctly working with gasprom but i
have also a lot of academic
uh also positions true so i want to be
here as a politician
uh navalny is uh of course a
representative
of uh the very young generation
in russia or the young generation who
have never experienced communism who
never experienced this kind of fear
which their relatives
fathers and grandfathers grandmothers
mothers have experienced during their
life
this is a generation which grew up with
i would say democratic traditions in the
90s but
felt this more positively than their
relatives who suffered in the 90s
and they have a kind of perspective for
russia which is completely different
from that of the and here i come to the
point
of the majority of the russians who
still are conservative traditionalists
and who want to have a strong russia
first of all
the majority of people in russia
will not follow navalny because
they have our other values and many of
them are also oriented negatively toward
the west
because of the 90s where a lot of
the the west is being seen as as a
failure for to for for
assistance to russia but on the other
hand of course for putin and for the
kremlin it's a big danger
that if navalny could unite and
organized the urban use
behind his political platform also the
political
platform of him is not quite
understandable is for me
at least he is against corruption but we
don't know is he
more right-wing is he more left-wing he
would
need to explain himself a very mixed
record he makes an effort
and he wants to become president this is
also his character he
i think he doesn't want to be a position
leader he doesn't want to sit in the
parliament
he fights personally with putin and this
is again
something what makes uh the political
career of him of himself
in the future very dangerous okay let's
see yeah if i could follow up on that
because i think it's going to be
interesting to see what the young
generation in russia does now
because if you look over the last 25
years the russian population
has been i don't want to i may be
passive i mean volatile
the the protest that you saw a hundred
thousand people in
2011 in moscow but mosque is a city of
what
15 million 13 yeah right right in kiev
in the maidan revolution sometimes you
had a half a million people on the
streets
in ukraine in a city of 3 million so
the russian population has not yet come
to the streets in the way that you've
seen people come to the streets in
ukraine
or in eastern europe earlier in the 90s
or in maybe even belarus but the
question is going to be is does that
younger generation now
come out and i think it was interesting
two things about
the protests on saturday one was
the numbers that you cited 100 cities
all across russia
that's pretty widespread the second
issue that i thought was kind of
interesting is that when you watch the
protests
the protesters were pushing back in the
past if you
at least as i've watched russian protest
the protesters are relatively
docile i mean they don't really push
back against the authorities in the way
that i think we saw happening on
saturday
and that might be of concern to russian
security services
okay very important point uh daria is up
next first of all though vladimir putin
has controlled power in russia for two
decades
but his leadership has become
increasingly authoritarian
and now for the first time there appears
to be a real challenger to his dominance
he is the pop star of the russian
opposition alexey navalny
is mobilizing people across the country
his goal
a russia free from corruption and putin
in video exposes posted on his youtube
channel
the law graduate explains how russia is
being robbed by its elites
he has been experiencing ever more of
the state's power through arrests and
court trials
his popularity is growing especially
among the young but he is also
controversial
initially aligned with the liberal
democratic party yabloco
navalny later temporarily relied on
nationalist
he finished second in moscow's 2013
mayoral elections
in the 2018 presidential election he was
barred from running against putin
two years later he was attacked with a
novichok nerve poison
presumably by secret agents of the fsb
the russian president makes fun of
navalny without ever mentioning his name
if they had wanted to fatally poison him
they would have brought it to the end
upon his return from germany where he
was treated and he recovered
the kremlin critic was again arrested
how dangerous can navalny still be
for the president
so much to talk about the voice of young
russia
i was just wanted to bring up one thing
is that we're talking about protests and
the scale of them and yes it is
impressive
but right next door to russia is belarus
a country which has been protesting on
the streets since august
every week sometimes even more we had
hundreds of thousands of people
turning up every day they have been
arrested beaten up they still haven't
given up
but lukaszenko and his regime also
haven't given up
belarus politically essentially remains
the same country that it was
it hasn't changed which and they have a
charismatic leader
certainty honors i would say for
many younger people from russia and from
belarus there has been a lot of writing
about vitality hanover in russia she's
interesting for us she's understandable
she is
more mainstream than navalny
i have to ask the question the question
that begs is is there something more
generally
happening here or we're not just talking
about absolutely
something general is happening here the
west was an anchor for russia in the
in the in the end of the 80s when
gorbachev started the
the revolution the perestroika people
were looking towards the west
as the best alternative to the soviet
regime now the west is
less and less for the majority of people
an alternative
it is sad for the western ears to hear
it but it's true
because the west has itself problems and
it has the same demonstrations
the west is badly organized the west is
is violent
uh this is too primitive no he's saying
they have the same problems
they have the same police brutal police
which is beating up demonstrators in the
united states and germany and holland
and so on so don't teach us
and the problem is that the russian
society is becoming anti-western in many
sense not the younger people
but the older people and the
traditionalists in russia are
saying we want to live in europe but in
a different
uh system of values and i think the the
conflict of values between the liberal
europe
and the non-liberal traditionalists
russia and many parts belarus and other
countries
is the main conflict which we have seen
in
between the west and russia in the past
20 okay let's pass the ball on yeah no
but i'm not sure i totally agree because
if you look at the maidan revolution in
ukraine in 2014
while it morphed into a broader protest
against
the kleptocracy of viktor yanukovych and
the growing authoritarianism
it started out as a protest because
yanukovych said he was not going to sign
an association agreement with the
european union
and for a lot of ukrainians they saw
this saying you're taking away
my chance to draw closer to europe so i
think europe still has a draw it may not
have the gloss that it did say 15 or 20
years ago and the question is going to
be in a place like russia where i think
you're right
there's this clash of values do younger
russians say no we still
want the values of europe and then how
does that work out internally with
russia
i think the problem russia has is i
think russia would
there's a segment of the russian
population and i think this might
include many people in the kremlin
who would like to join europe but on
russian terms
and i'm not sure that europe is prepared
to accept russian values
and i think that's the clash there my
point was that the values of europe have
changed
you might disagree but it's also true
the west has become somehow militant
also in in in in the wars a lot of i i
work with many russians in the
pediatrician
we're talking about angela merkel's
germany which can hardly be described as
a
as a fatuously liberal society we can
uh we can talk germany is probably the
best model
for a liberal democracy in the world as
i'm saying this is a german but in this
on the same time we see that we are
having certain
problems and we are problems inside
europe too that's not the subject of our
talk right now i'm always talking about
the russians
who i work with with young people in the
in the us parliaments in russia
made a survey there they're saying yes
we want to be part of europe we want
european values but not at any price the
west should stop
teach us we also have something to bring
into this europe this is
this is not a contradiction what to what
you have said it's only
as i'm not even a correction but uh an
an an important point which i wanted
to make that things have changed a
little bit from the times
which we know when the the the colored
revolutions and the other revolutions
were conducted or took place in eastern
europe okay
uh that was the world in many ways
according to vladimir putin and he
vladimir putin the russian leader has
surprised many people by actually
responding
to navalny's documentary that we heard
about the russian leader
said he hadn't yet seen the film but he
nevertheless dismissed it as
boring and brainwashing for the first
time navalny used the film to attack
putin directly there's plenty of footage
of the lavish
black sea palace the largest palace in
the world apparently
uh alexander you are uh
you're you're giggling in the background
almost uh did
how corrupt is vladimir putin
i think he's not himself is not corrupt
russia is corrupt
and uh he doesn't need this much doesn't
mean he's not corrupt
personally he's not corrupt i don't
think that he has uh personal
values i don't think so it has to be
proved i don't think so you ask me
i think around him the oligarchs are
corrupt the world
in in russia has a problem of corruption
the major problem
he has his cronies i will explain to you
this this castle why they are
building this to demonstrate the world
that it can do
built a better castle than the french uh
400 years ago
yes they have enough but they want to
have more yes yes we laugh at this and
i'm trying to explain what they wanted
to create a big monument
uh for for a strong russia at the coast
yes for us it's ridiculous
but for them i think it's a it's a it's
a symbol of power
to to show the presence at the black sea
like the palace that we remember so well
in the romanian capital bucharest
this is far more i think more expensive
but it's built by the oligarchs and i
can't
reject of course probably one day they
thought that putin might use his castle
when he steps down but he's not stepping
down
yeah and i think that's it's been
interesting that while the kremlin says
you know putin has nothing to do with
this
uh they could say who owns it who built
it and they're totally silent on that
point
so it's clearly it's not being built for
somebody else and i think in the absence
of any further information
you know it's clearly been built for
putin on the broader question
i mean whether or not putin is
personally corrupt we may have different
views on that he has tolerated an
incredible amount of corruption in
russia
and i guess that was probably the
biggest surprise when i was still in the
u.s government back in the
2000s when putin came to power i think
the one thing that we really expected
was he will
tighten some things up i mean i think
there was a sense in russia that things
had become
too loose in the 1990s too much chaos so
he would restore a degree of order
but there's also a sense that this is
somebody who will actually you know
crack down on corruption
and i don't think we've seen that
crackdown somebody said
somebody who would who would be he was
viewed as an honest leader
a man who stood by his word that was the
that was always the message around putin
there was hope i mean i don't remember
2012
but age dropper yeah but
uh there was hope that something will
change that russia will become
the westernest country that so many
people hoped for it would in the 90s and
the mass would be
cleaned up and we would have a normal
life
and it has not come to fruition
you had in the demonstrations there were
a lot of young people who said i haven't
seen another president other than
vladimir putin i can say the same there
was even a meme that there is not a cat
in russia that has been born before
putin it's a joke in the cash lifetime
but it's true just
i think he's such a focal point of this
corruption that many people have
associated him he has ingrained himself
so much
in the fabric of the russian society
that if we want change he has to go
it's sentiment among many i think the
basic problem is that russia has
no idea what is enlightenment we in the
west
and the united states went through this
period of enlightenment the russians
didn't have it they jumped from
communism from a totalitarian system
with gulags and with major kgb into
something else into capitalism
where uh everybody tried to become rich
the corruption is the problem of the
whole society
the people at the top are very rich but
people at the below are also in many
ways corrupt unfortunately not only in
russia but in in eastern europe they
think it's normal
that's a way of life in order to survive
they don't think it's good
but they think it's a way to survive
what they say they at the top
shouldn't steal too many too much money
and
now of course this castle is showing
that uh
corruption is is exploding at the top
and this is what makes people of course
wonder whether
is now finally an alternative a genuine
viable alternative to the putin rule
that we've seen now for
two for 20 years i think it's too early
to say
i mean you do have to see
what happens on sunday i mean are you
going to see the sort of evolution that
you saw in belarus where people are
prepared to go into the streets on a
more regular basis
i don't think at this point we can gauge
how powerful
navalny's pull is but he's also going up
against a very organized authoritarian
system
a very established police state that you
know is going to push back
and that's going to be the clash i i
personally i think putin made a tactical
i think
arresting navalny on navalny's return
actually has put putin in a box because
you know he now has to do something
you know back down or perhaps send
navalny to jail for a number of years
and that's going to get attention in
navalny
that navalny might not have attracted
had he simply come back
and been allowed to return and then go
on with whatever he was going to do
what evidence would you if this were a
sort of a council of wise men and women
which
indeed it is in many ways if the german
government were to come along and say
what advice do you have for for us uh in
in approaching this crisis in russia
with the two
with the with the putin regime and the
navalny challenge
uh i think the west should um continue
sanctioning especially the oligarchs the
corrupt top of the russian society who
have
a lot of assets in europe and there have
been a lot of investigations coming out
i'm not saying that
the western power should act on the
pointers from navalny's team that's
definitely not the case but that they
should
maybe have a better look of people who
get uh
european citizenship the practice of the
golden passports so-called on
cyprus has been discontinued for now but
a lot of people have got them so
practices like this as long as something
like this is happening in the west
putin and the likes of him have the full
freedom to claim
they're not better than us no i think
there's actually
one good development in the united
states is with the law that was passed
in december
it's now going to ban the ability of
shell companies tone real estate and
assets in the united states
i suspect there's a huge amount of real
estate in miami
in new york that's owned by russian
oligarchs probably ukrainian oligarchs
and it's all owned through shell
companies so we don't know who
you're going to have to now disclose the
beneficial owner
and that will be useful in a number of
ways for example if there's a decision
then to target
individual oligarch we then know who to
go after
i guess i would throw out a second idea
which i i hesitate because it's somewhat
un-american
i mean we don't tend to hold families
responsible for the act of the father
but i do wonder if if the west looked at
sanctioning not just
the oligarch but families i mean if an
older guard can't travel to europe
that's one thing
but if the spouse can't make her annual
shopping trip to london or if the kids
can't go to college
that might have a different impact and
it's harsh you know but
you know it might be a way to target
some sanctions that actually begin to
stir up some concern among the people
who i think are
close in the putin inner circle it
sounds very plausible to me but you know
more about these things alexander tell
us is that there are problems with
um doing this because many of these
people have
british or german or american
citizenship
and you can't punish or sanction your
own citizens in this way
and of course people want to will i i
don't want to sound too cynical attract
russian money
of course for their own banks for on
purpose in the west
and the and the the real problem i think
is i i don't know what to do but i think
that if the sanctions will be too
harsh if for example not stream two will
be
completely stopped and there are
assigned to putin
we are against you then this will
mobilize of course more and more people
not for but against navalny and against
the west
in russia we should see this one thing
that people
uh as i followed the story in in
the past couple of weeks one thing that
people have said a lot of people have
said
is that they're very impressed by the
courage shown by alex
navalny in returning to the country and
i wonder because it has been talked
about and because he has indicated that
he has thought about it
and and we need to understand the
gravity of the situation here wonk this
is the question
is his life at risk i think it is
nobody is completely safe in the russian
jail as we know from
the case of mr magnitsky and how many
others
let's not forget about the covet
outbreak which obviously you have
outbreaks of covet in russian jails and
i don't think navalny is fully healthy
after the chemical attack it cannot be
100 healthy yeah no they i mean
i think the russian security services
tried to kill him once uh that should be
a message
uh and certainly i think he's at risk of
spending a long time in jail i mean they
will find reasons to keep him in jail
and again though there's that question
is that the smart thing for the kremlin
to do because to the extent that they
either keep him in jail or if in fact
you know he he does die under mysterious
circumstances
you know that's going to make him more
of a martyr and how does that then react
with the population that's
inclined to support him he has already
let it be known that he will not commit
suicide he will not take his own life
and that seems to be a sort of a
reassurance to the world that you know
or
reassurance an indication that he
believes that
you know he could be knocked off if
something happens he's saying it wasn't
by my own hand
yeah but he wants doesn't want to give
up he wants to fight for the presidency
i think he wants to become the top man
in russia
and therefore he had to return there was
no alternative no option for him to stay
here and work for uh
deutsche weller for someone else i mean
or for radio liberty
i mean that would be his fate here of
course he wants to go back to fight
otherwise he would
lose of course his electorate and i
think that was the kremlin's hope that
he would simply he would stay there
at the criminal what are they going to
do to bring him into prison this will uh
highlight
navain's points again and made him even
more popular to
uh be after him or god bless me not
to to to poison him would be even a more
disastrous
mistake so the solzhenitsyn uh
option out back to germany stripped of
citizenship sent into action i can't
imagine that it will happen it will
happen but
i'm not i i think that this is one of
the very
few but options which in the end
may come up we began with daria so let's
give daria the final word yeah
it's a people in the west like to talk
about or very often liberals in the west
talk about the ultimate demise of
vladimir putin
would russia be a better place after
putin
i think there is a chance to improve for
russia after putin is gone but it's not
a guarantee can become worse
for all we know you could have some kind
of political junta uh
you don't know that's the thing it's
gonna be a wild play
okay uh russia after putin
uh thanks very much for joining us i
hope you've enjoyed our conversation
i hope we've given you plenty of food
for thought if you have enjoyed the show
come back next time until then bye bye
and cheers
[Music]
[Music]
you